hello everyone i've had a really busy
work week uh so i did not watch the
nintendo direct because i
you know had work while it was live so
now with a
small chunk of spare time that i have i
thought that i would catch up on a bunch
of the trailers that i have missed that
i feel like everyone's been talking
about for the last few days
snyder cut and then i'll check out the
major things from the nintendo direct
that i missed because i don't even know
what the major news was let's do
snydercut
snyder cut trailer four days ago
alrighty
[Music]
it looks very snyder
[Music]
the god is dead
i had a dream
almost like a premonition this is gonna
be so complicated to make uh
i'd love to see a documentary about this
whole thing it's fascinating
you've really been losing their minds
over so many characters in that scene
i've seen that
i need warriors he does look a lot
better i'm building an alliance
to defend ourselves oh
am i crazy face just looked awful
to defend us
that's not good you don't want that in
your blockbuster film but okay
how do you know your team's strong
enough
if you can't bring down the charging
bull then don't wave the red cape at it
[Music]
she's a fantastic actress you're sitting
here for a reason
and even if it takes you the rest of
your life what a good visual effects
find out what that means batman
what that reason is that's a nice shot
[Music]
they said the age of heroes would never
come again
[Music]
it will it has to
we live in a society where honor
is a distant memory isn't that right
he said it he really said it batman
we're just really not a fan of this
joker just collectively society is
is anti this joker um so this is a
visually impressive trailer and again i
feel like this is uh
such a difficult thing to do i think
it's really interesting
um there are precedents that could be
concerning to me
uh about you know how much
fan demand could change
sort of creative visions um
with enough pressure i guess i feel like
this is a unique circumstance because of
all the stuff that happened with snyder
uh definitely feels different to the
others
um but what i will say about this
trailer is while i think it is
like quite visually impressive
if i didn't already know what justice
league is about
and i didn't already know some of you
know what snyder wanted to get out of
justice league
i feel like this is a trailer about
nothing
like if you didn't know and you saw this
trailer you'd be like what
there's some kind of some kind just some
kind of wall
like what what is this film about um i
don't know if i'm the only one reading
it that way though
but i feel like it's just a lot of shots
of of like sort of gal gado
looking stressed which is fine she's
very attractive
people seem to be really excited it does
look like a completely different film i
agree with that
it just must be really difficult to have
done this
uh it's gonna be really interesting to
see how it turns out like how they did
it
people are excited that's that's good
i'm happy to see people be excited
i feel like some of the snyder cut fans
have been very very aggressive um
to anyone who's kind of uninterested
like i might even get some [ __ ] in the
comments of this video just for saying
that i feel like this trailer
for people who don't already know what
it's about maybe won't tell you much
about what it's about like they'll
probably
they seem to be angry enough that i
could get in trouble for that but
um i'm gonna watch it no doubt i
have absolutely no grasp of it's going
to be good or not definitely interested
in the production side of it like deeply
deeply interested in how that all went
down i think it's really fascinating
trailer has some cool shots that's kind
of the the extent of
my participation in that it's nintendo
time i think
i guess i could go to nintendo's youtube
channel and just pick things from here
that look
cool right like if i just go to a day
ago all alright we'll check out mario
golf shall we
the fairway is open once again
[Music]
tee off on the latest installment of the
mario golf series
coming to nintendo switch it definitely
does look like mario gold
i agree with that take your time to
think things through
then swing
[Music]
i really like mario
on courses filled with lush natural
scenery
oh heck you hate to see it in addition
to button controls
you can also use motion controls by
holding a joy-con controller like a golf
club
that's neat certainly swing the
controller to have your character swing
in the game
that's cool that's cool i like it
sensation
of golfing
you just got on top of all [ __ ] left by
[Music]
they kept that unintentionally what is
that several modes some kind of
mechanics
truly bring the heat to mario kart no
including
this one speed golf
here it's always your turn everyone tees
off at the same time
then you'll race through the course
that's fun that's fun
another whack to get it closer to the
hole then keep going
that will be really really silly to come
out on top
when mario golf super rush swings onto
nintendo switch
june 25th pre-orders begin on nintendo
eshop
after this presentation cool with it
looks fun
i think that new mode will be really
really fun what else have we got in here
no more heroes is pretty dope ooh ooh
what is this
animal crossing you say super mario
themed items are coming to your island
what super mario brothers 35th
anniversary themed
strong with your face
cool familiar items like the super
mushroom
and the question block can be ordered in
game as furniture items
i love it so place them however and
wherever you'd like
i my animal crossing island there's a
video here on this channel
pipes for transport
oh my god between locations that's
that's incredible
look at them why not making the game
more playable
oh that's so cool
a free update for the game launches
february 25th
i had no idea i can't believe super
mario brothers items will be available
via nook shopping starting march 1st
keep an eye on the official animal
crossing twitter account for the latest
information i can't believe i didn't
like i have any
i didn't know about any of this i didn't
have this spoiled for me by anyone
in a whole day the internet is slacking
continue enjoying life on your island
damn
yeah i have a i built a pokemon stadium
you can you can
see fully out of pixels it was really
difficult um
the video is on is on this channel maybe
like leave a link to it
uh if they had pokemon later that would
that would really help me out
and also i would really like it so
there's that tube that's neat
big fan okay what else you got for me
nintendo skyward
sword huh what'd you say
this guy was sold on the switch how does
it look
[Music]
yeah i saw their faces it looks good
it's not like blowing away good but it
looks good
i do really like skyward sword link's
design
you know it's um not everyone's favorite
zelda
[Music]
put that back in there
how is this four minutes what's what are
you hiding
from me what you've just seen is the
legend of zelda skyward sword hd
this game originally released in 2011 on
the wii console
and now it's coming to nintendo switch
the legend of zelda skyward sword
featured a control scheme in which
players would use the wii remote
it did i did not like it as a shield
with the increased processing power of
the nintendo switch system the controls
here are smoother
and even more intuitive and we've
recreated the controls for the sword and
the shield here
by having the player hold two joy-con
controllers
the joy-con controller in your right
hand i mean the joy-con is a huge
improvement they really haven't iterated
on that
swing his sword in the game that's cool
the joy-con controller in your left hand
is the shield
by lifting the controller you can raise
the shield to block enemies
i'll try it but i i can't see myself
wanting to play perform other actions
like using both controllers to wield the
bow and arrow
these physical movements add a sense of
urgency and tension to combat you know
it is a good way to get like a vague
amount of exercise i also made it
possible to play the game with button
controls to ensure it can be played in
handheld mode or on the nintendo lesson
system that's what we want over how to
assign different game players
to different buttons we decided to apply
the sword motions to tilting the right
control stick
interesting
tilt the stick down when you want to
swing the sword downward
to swing to the right to the left metal
gear rising revengeance did some of that
stuff and it was actually pretty
sick in the respective direction
here's something else we've been working
on
specially designed joycon the right
joy-con controller is themed after the
master sword while the left features a
hylian shield motif
i like it
itself we hope that people who played
the original game
that's cool playing it for the first
time will enjoy discovering the origins
of the legend of zelda
that rules skyward sword was the last
original console game prior to the
legend of zelda breath of the wild game
and it was still following the
established conventions of the legend of
zelda however it gave a glimpse into
many features and innovations that would
eventually be adopted in the legend of
zelda breath of the wild
that's true using the sail cloth to
descend in mid-air
a stamina gauge that depleted as you
scaled walls with blinds or ran
even the concept of collecting items to
upgrade gear
i hope those of you who've played the
legend of zelda breath of the wild will
give this game a try as well
that's an interesting marketing tactic
is that they know that people don't like
skyward sword as much so they're trying
to be like well it's kind of similar to
breath of the wild though
um no i was going to say this sword sits
by my front door
and i you could see just this part of it
um
in an instagram story that i posted once
and some guy uh
really caused a stink i think there were
two of them actually um because they
thought that i had a dildo
they were like oh my god this stupid
streamer just had a dildo sitting next
to her desk and and filmed it
and put it on her instagram story
it's it's just a monster sword my friend
it's just a monster sword you don't have
one by your front door what are you
gonna do if you get boggled
okay what else do we have capcom arcade
stadium
bravely default 2 i really like bravely
default
out of wilds is is an incredible game
an incredible game um really difficult
to play initially for a lot of people
please try it please just
stick through that starting bit that i
know a lot of people really don't enjoy
um where you're kind of learning how to
use your spaceship
uh but beyond that point that game is
so good uh ah brilliant time for people
to jump on
i've always been a huge fan of ninja
gaiden tales from the borderlands is
also pretty exciting um
as something that's the unforgiving
world of pandora entails felt like it
was kind of lost play as the hyperion
lackey rhys
and the quick-witted con artist fiona as
you set out to recover a mountain of
cash
set between borderlands 2 and 3 this
game includes all five episodes
gangsters bandit lords and choices are
just a handful of the obstacles you'll
encounter in this choice driven i think
most people say that it's the best of
them
when tails from the borderlands episodic
bunch of switch
i will play through that i will do it
that's super exciting
um i think i'll leave it there you know
there's a bunch more trailers here
obviously but those are the main ones
that i feel like i really needed to see
to catch up on the alana isms thank you
all for joining me today i will see you
guys next time
sorry snider cup fans please don't get
mad at me because i said the trailer was
maybe
wouldn't make sense to anyone bye